he attacks us with nuclear weapons
danger will come not just from blast
or heat
or nearby radiation effect
but also from fallout
fallout which may occur miles and miles
away from the blast
you need to know about fallout
what it is
how to detect it
and what to do to protect yourself
against it
everybody needs to know
yes this does mean you
watch and listen
one day
these facts may save your life
what is this fallout anyhow
just bits of radio act fall out of the
mushroom cloud of the nuclear explosion
and settle on the ground
these bits of matter can be dangerous
you're exposed to some radiation every
day from cosmic rays or other natural
sources of radiation
these exposures are too small to hurt
you
but when a wartime nuclear explosion
occurs
a serious fallout follows
thousands of tons of atomized earth
building materials rocks and gases may
be thrown into the air
and the mushroom cloud containing them
sometimes moves as high as 100 000 feet
nearly 20 miles up
some of the radioactive particles spill
out near the explosion site
others may be carried for 10 50 100
miles or more
but how will you know if there is
fallout
you can't hear smell
taste or see the radiation
but you yourself can detect the fallout
particles that produce it
the easiest time to do this without
special instruments
is when the fallout is settling through
the air
this starts anytime from about one half
hour to several hours after the
explosion
depending on how far away you are
and it continues to fall for an hour or
longer
usually you can see the fallout
so if there has been an explosion of a
nuclear weapon within a 200 miles of you
you should suspect every unusual
concentration of dust in the air of
being fallout
after an explosion in daylight watch any
unusual accumulation of dust
at night put a white or light colored
plate outside
examine it every 15 minutes or so
if dust is accumulated on the plate
treat it as fallout
the particles in that fallout behaves
like miniature x-ray machines
sending out radiation in all directions
if there are many particles and if you
are exposed to them long enough
you will be hurt
others will be watching for that fallout
of course
experts will estimate the probable path
and speed of approaching fallout and try
to keep you posted
but it may come before you hear any
details by radio or otherwise
you must take precautions
whether you hear their reports or not
if radio stations are operating you'll
hear reports
especially on the connell rad
frequencies 640 or 1240 on your am dial
as soon as it is safe for specially
protected crews to get out into the open
these highly trained civil defense
radiation detection teams
will make a thorough check of radiation
levels and characteristics
those facts will be relayed to you by
radio
as fast as they come into civil defense
headquarters in your area
information from the radiation
monitoring teams will be combined and
analyzed by experts manning a central
radiation control point
these experts who know just how fast
harmful radiation reduces in force
can predict when it will be safe for
people to come out of shelters
and resume normal tasks
we have warned that you may have to act
before you get any detailed reports
just what can you do
if fallout comes your way
find the best shelter you can
the more solid substance you can put
between yourself and the fallout
the better
but an ordinary frame house with windows
closed will give considerable protection
in a house it's best to get on the floor
away from doors and windows
or if you can find a location with
additional walls in the center of the
building
a basement is even better if the house
has one
large buildings such as apartment or
office buildings give good protection
the thick heavy masonry of their walls
and floors
makes it hard for radiation to get
through
basements
inside rooms or corridors on the lower
floors are safest
the basement of any house or building
will become a good improvised shelter if
you block the windows with sandbags
and place other sandbags on the floor
above the shelter area
if you don't have sandbags
thick solid layers of books
magazines or newspapers
or even a series of file cabinets
standing close to each other can cut the
radiation danger
in some parts of the country there are
storm cellars or outside vegetable
storage sellers
they may be used as shelters from
fallout
if you plan to use such a seller or your
basement or any other shelter
stock it with food and supplies
to equip and supply your shelter area
you need some of the same things you
might take on a vacation camping trip
first sleeping equipment to fit your
shelter area
folding cuts
or sleeping bags
and blankets
then food and water
there should be at least a two-week
supply
you'll want plenty of fruit juices and
lots of your family's favorite canned
foods
the drinking water supply should be
rotated often to be sure it's fresh
and don't forget such basic needs as
sugar
salt pepper and other seasoning that
your family ordinarily uses
now some equipment
a radio is very important
it should be a battery portable with
spare batteries
a transistorized radio is best as the
batteries last longer
next you need light in the form of
flashlights and a battery operated
lantern
then a good first aid kit
now plates cups silverware
a can opener and a bottle opener are
important
add to these things enough closed
containers to take care of garbage and
human waste
especially if there will be children in
the shelter include some books and
magazines
paper and pencils
maybe one or two small simple games
the best protection of all is the
special shelter built according to
specifications of your local civil
defense organization
this has an air filter to allow
ventilation but keep dust out
and it has at least three feet of earth
over it
it would be a good idea to go right now
to your local civil defense office to
secure plans for the type of shelter you
want
and then to get busy on construction
plans are simple
using standard materials
so maybe you can do the job yourself
but all this special shelter talk won't
help very much if you are caught way out
on the open road
if that happens keep driving until you
see a building which may be a house or
barn
church or school
drive as close to the building as you
can
then get yourself and your family out of
the car
and take cover in the building
if you live on a farm and have
sufficient warning
get your animals under cover
and give them enough food and water to
last several days
and if you can
cover any piles of hay or harvested
crops that may be outside
if the explosion has been some miles
away
you will have time to fill tubs and
other containers with water
before fallout arrives
all locations where outside dust does
not penetrate will be safe storage
points for water
whatever kind of shelter you find
settle down and make the best of it
if there are others with you
help them by being as calm as you can
and don't be discouraged
you can go out for very brief periods if
you are well covered and keep the dust
off your skin
wear heavy boots or shoes
and pants tucked in or tied around the
bottom to keep dust out
if any dust gets on you
brush it off promptly
and when you have a chance wash it off
that dust can burn your skin
but what happens if you do get exposed
to a great deal of fallout
food or water has been contaminated by
the dust
internal damage may occur
when dust has been left on skin
there will be skin burns
when you have been near dust too long
there may be radiation sickness
exposure can even cause death
if you have had considerable exposure
you will vomit and grow weak but after a
few hours this sensation will pass
and by the next day you may have had the
last of it
even if you have been exposed to
excessive fallout
you may eat and drink just as you
normally would but don't force yourself
whether you have had these symptoms or
not
if civil defense radio announcements
have said that radiation has been high
in your section
keep an eye on your condition for the
next few days
watch especially for these developments
in the two weeks following exposure
return of nausea
sore throat
spots developing without any known
reason
loss of hair
these conditions
or nose bleed
or diarrhea
should be reported to a doctor
or to the nearest first aid station set
up under civil defense plans
unless civil defense teams have warned
that your area is still dangerously
radioactive
you can get out and work to help
yourself and help others
although fallout can be deadly
your chances of avoiding damage from it
are much better if you follow the
directions we have given you
during an alert keep your portable radio
tuned to the conrad radio frequencies
640
and 1240 on the am dial
for the latest reports and advice
right now
today before there is an alert
take time to learn the civil defense
five steps to safety
learn warning signals and what they mean
learn your community plan for emergency
action
learn protection from radioactive
fallout
learn first aid and home emergency
preparedness steps
and
learn how to use connell rad 640 or 1240
on the am dial
for official directions
you